hey guys welcome to the American Music
Awards red carpet I'm Christian Zamora
and I'm curly Velasquez and we're gonna
have Thanksgiving dinner with all the
stars you brought your appetite get
ready for a mouthful well welcome to our
Thanksgiving dinner do you want some
bread really have nothing to offer hi
does the black family have any
traditions for Thanksgiving we always go
look at like lights and stuff like that
all the premature lights around town
we're a pretty boring family oh my good
as well Jesus is our it looks like get
this out of the way what do you have
here yeah so welcome to Thanksgiving
Charlie I think I'm gonna have a
friendsgiving there you go I'll FaceTime
my mom and dad rest of the family and
Thanksgiving is more like adults ish
that so-called adult age well it's like
the weirdest thing that they've ever
served at Thanksgiving dinner I'm not a
fan of lamb or like weird needs like
rabbit and everything at least once and
then if it's not for you like your men
all my friends houses and all my family
houses and I'm like totally great for
the free food yeah that's so smart like
why make your own Thanksgiving you know
just feed everyone else you know [ __ ]
marry kill we have mashed potatoes
we have cranberry sauce and pumpkin pie
I would marry mashed potatoes because
they're like wholesome [ __ ] pumpkin pie
that's like cranberry sauce but I'm
gonna have to kill this boy down the
drain any celebrity debtor live that you
could invite over to your Thanksgiving
dinner who would it be
jealousy good answer my family would
probably not like her but like I would
be oh my gosh it would make it all about
her Donna you're praying right now all
right that was Thanksgiving on the red
carpet with BuzzFeed I'm Christian
Zamora I'm clearly the last good thanks
for watching
[Music]
[Music]